does it have any suggestions we're
trying to determine what this is equal
to a great clue you know yeah that let
the whole function equal something like
what like hey now what
take take sine of both sides to side
because I seek I'm just gonna get sine
squared sine sine of s okay what's that
mean he's this is interesting by the way
this isn't the way that I was going to
go but this is going somewhere in anyone
when what do you guys need to use we
look at that hmm let me let me rewind
back to the beginning of our lesson
earlier today right we've got sine
inverse of something well cause you mess
with something what's the first thing
you think what is it actually equal to
and the answer is you know for instance
let's go back to this guy okay sine
inverse of 3 or 5 right where is that in
this diagram
where would I put it but it's a it's an
angle it's a bit isn't it it's better
right
if you define theta as this angle yes so
I can actually say let's call that sine
inverse three on five right I can also
say it's equal to cos inverse all right
so this is talking to angles in relation
to each other okay now I'm gonna I'm
gonna go with this I'm gonna romba this
idea what triangle could I make which
would actually be useful for me that
could tell me that could give me some
you know insight into what this is
actually equal to it okay
so cos inverse of X is this angle over
here okay so what's sine of that angle
if I said this is this is cos inverse
that angle there is causing mister form
file
right so what's the sine of that angle
come on guys this is like the first
thing we learn in unite trick it's a
right angle triangle right side of that
angle there which is cos what's it equal
to three or five right in other words we
have sine of this angle causing there's
something in terms of the other sides
okay now I don't have concrete numbers
I'm interested in this analytically
right how'd you break that can I come up
with a triangle it's gonna be useful to
me okay so rather than a 3 4 5 triangle
if I call this angle over here cos
inverse of X what does that tell me
about the sides of this writing
different number one yeah concentration
X right another way I could write it is
cos inverse of X on one right because
cos is adjacent on hypotenuse right
Jason on hypotenuse yeah so what's the
other side rooms one - next his way to
sunrise is Pythagoras right yes it's
actually one square it might say to it
but you gotta get it okay so therefore
from this triangle what side of
it's its opposite all right what news
right that's interesting because I know
what this shape is right what shape is
this if I were to graph if I asked you
to graph this J what is it it's a
semicircle there's a semicircle right
that's us isn't it because you know the
tree functions we often they're
sometimes called even in yellow fits it
calls them the circular punches that's
kind of interesting
okay what about the other combinations
what about the cause of sine inverse
okay
well what about what other kinds of
combinations inverse or what I miss okay
I drew you a triangle this one here
right there told you what this ratio is
equal to I wonder if you can work out
whatever some of that triangle will do
you that one down the bottom although
probably these two as well but this one
you'll need a new triangle so what you
have to think about it okay